hammoum pas là mon papa me
[Musique]
tiens bon jour il fait beau aujourd'hui
d'un mille aux enfants n'est ce pas moi
je suis content heureux en pleine forme
j'ai pris un bain je me suis mis de
l'eau de cologne et je me trouve très
jolie
asseyez-vous fait qu'est ce qui se passe
alors je vous en prie mais qu'est ce qui
vous arrive et
qu'est ce que je peux qu'est ce qui se
passe chez nous et là c'est une de mes
chaussures allées larges zones
d'australie oui
je suis tombé dans l'escalier de ma
maison
je me suis cassé du temps regardez déjà
fort mais ça c'est pas bien joli pauvre
monsieur du snj
et du snj a perdu deux dents et il se
trouve à fond alors moi qui n'est pas
dans du tout je dois être horrible
aussi les jolies mais il est écrasé non
mais vous imaginez mon nez je vais
comprendre ce système ça doit être
terrible
mais moi je n'ai pas non plus hein
c'était affreux et aimant crâne tout
écorché j'ai perdu presque tous mes
cheveux ces nouveaux pose plus
alami mais moi je n'ai pas un seul se
veut non plus alors moi sont nés sans
cheveux s'endort je dois être un monstre
enfants la femme au rang triste vous
allez monsieur du snav monsieur liste ne
faut pas vous laisser aller tout ça ça
va s'arranger
limonade ça va vous réconfort notre
gentil vous me réconforter beaucoup
qu'une petite limon
ça vous faire du bien
[Musique]
mais mes parts on fait pas julie je vais
vous protéger je suis casimir qu'est ce
qui dit s'appelle casimir ouais c'est
moi me reconnaissais pas toi qui case in
iraq azimi ah bah oui c'est casimir je
reconnais sa voix mais non mon voeu que
j'u mûre pour que tu veux sur le lait
fait vous avez dit tout à l'heure comme
monsieur du snob était affreux sang dans
son nez et sans cheveux callen c'est
pour ça que tu t'es vu ses ouailles et
alors m'enfin ce qui est vrai que
monsieur blé pas pour toi tu as dû
beaucoup plus beau sens dans son nez et
sans le feu c'est vrai
qu'ils pensent aussi françois mais oui
je le pense chacun de nous est beau
comme il est il faut pas vouloir essayer
de ressembler aux autres quand
je suis content je suis comparé au smic
compte un pauvre monsieur du sénat ben
tiens valérie prête moi ta raquette
voilà attention j'ai une idée venez là
monsieur du snob ouvre grand la bouche
fait aaa
voilà bien aaa
[Applaudissements]
mais je voulais enlever les quelques
dents qui restent à monsieur du ch'nord
pour qu'il soit aussi beau que moi kazim
historia compris
[Musique]
comment vois-tu casimir qu'est-ce que ça
si vous m'avez fait peur je vais très
bien je vous remercie et et vous comment
tu allais pas joué merveilleusement bien
mon cadet mire figure toi que je me suis
réveillé l'âme poète et depuis ce matin
j'étais impatient de venir dans le
jardin pour écrire un petit bijou de
poèmes là c'est sur ce banc au milieu
des oiseaux sous le soleil est entourée
de tous mes amis et bien je suis très
content pour vous je vous laisse
travailler tranquille à à leur mercie
casimir à tout à l'heure bon voyons
voyons voyons voyons voyons
il est noir non il fait noir oui walaa
merveilleux voilà le petit bijou de
pointe qui commence il fait noir il fait
noir or
comme c'est agréable de travailler dans
ce jardin calme et tranquille
excusez moi monsieur du cinéma pardon je
ne voudrais pas vous déranger mais je ne
veux pas troubler votre inspiration ni
vous ennuyer bruit les autres kazemi
reçoit bref s'il te plaît parce que je
ne pourrai jamais trouver la fin de mon
poème vous savez quand je vous aime
beaucoup et que nous sommes maintenant
de grands amis ça c'est vrai se content
que tu l'aies compris j'en voulais
également vous dire quand je vous trouve
grâce à un pack qui ça devrait aussi les
souabes reste que ces murs et bien voilà
je je suis très content que vous me
tutoyez se contenta plaisir que gémir
oui je consacrais agréable je suis
enchanté casimir mais pour l'amour du
ciel esma terminer mon petit bijou de
peau elle moment très bien je voulais ah
c'est ça c'est ça
ou un étage ah oui il fait noir ah ça
c'est très bien que c'est très beau et
puis c'est simple il fait noir tout le
monde connaît je tu il il fait il fait
chaud il fait froid non il fait noir
anneaux à la plus belle des couleurs
c'est merveilleux monsieur du sna qui
at-il encore et encore moi oui j'ai
réfléchi est ce possible
oui hein je couvrais beaucoup plus
simple si je vous tutoyait moi aussi
c'est absolument impossible
vraiment vraiment mon rang la naissance
ou l'éducation au savoir ne le
permettent pas je comprends c'est
dommage au revoir au revoir
où en est un jeu à oui il fait noir et
comme c'est agréable de dire il s'est
noirci le peignoir
doit à c'est simple il suffisait d'y
penser c'est moi 19 qui a pensé c'est
absolument délicieux c'est très embêtant
c'est même une catastrophe
monsieur du snob moi tu toi et moi je ne
vous vois si bien que les gens vont
penser qu'il m'est supérieur qu'il est
plus intelligent ou ou même plus beau
que moi
ce qui n'est pas vrai du tout non non il
faut qu' il faut qu'ils me vouvoie
également je vais arranger ça c'est pas
possible monsieur listenable que se
passe t'il encore je souhaiterais que
vous me vouvoyer comme autrefois comme
tu veux casimir mais pour l'amour du
ciel est ce moi travailler mais non
monsieur dissidence je ne veux pas me
laisser travailler messi mais vous avez
dit comme tu veux casimir et alors et
alors il fallait dire comme vous voulez
casimir bon si tu veux si tu veux je
dirai ce que tu voudras pourvu que tu me
laisses finir vos poèmes
vous ne comprenez rien du tout bon bon
bon j'ai compris et casimir décidé de
demandes juillet de mon péché finir mon
poème j'ai compris très bien mais pas du
tout enfin quand on tutoie les gens on
leur dit qu et si on voulait vous voyez
on leur vie vous c'est pas compliqué et
pourtant c'est si beau il fait noir il
fait noir oui il fait noir
mais alors si il fait noir c'est le soir
il faut que je rentre chez moi j'attends
casimir foutu répéter ce que tu veux te
dire ça te plait g10 il fait noir c'est
le soir c'est évident mais oui c'est
sans merveilleux casimir merci c'était
donc il fait noir c'est le soir au
zénith si tu veux te ferai le crès grand
plaisir de mettre ton verre dans nos
poèmes arbres aussi vous voulez j'ai
enfin le poème pour sal mais on est
absolument impossible mais tu peux
peut-être m'aider à faire le poème ça je
serais ravi de travailler avec vous me
manquez kazimiyah carte très sincèrement
je pense que ton génie créateur
complètent parfaitement lemire oui et
quand on aura terminé on arrêtera joly
et françois et nous leur livrons notre
chez devrait y sera génial casimir
écouter seulement il y a une petite
condition oui voilà j'ai
un marché à vous proposer eh bien
françois vite que ce que c'est je viens
de recevoir un mot de casimir me
demandant de réunir tous les enfants et
les personnes susceptibles d'apprécier
la bonne poésie de la police j'ai vite
s'il ne va pas tarder à arriver
formidable les enfants venez vite avec
nous sur le banc installez vous venez
venez vite vous allez voir ça va être
formidable casimir va nous dire ah
poèmes
le voilà monsieur des snobs et avec lui
bonjour tout le monde bonjour vous êtes
nous sommes prêts mais bien installé oui
allez-y monsieur jean ah bah je peux
commencer je vous en prie mon chat
casimir son temps françois monsieur du
snav a dit vous à casimir et oui
cher public adoré voici un poème composé
de trois propre et un post scriptum que
je ne mets pas si li té
première ostroff enfin
il seynois c'est le soir
un pas sans paps passe sans penser sans
penser qu'il fait noah et qu'il passe
dans le soir enfin chien le regarde pas
si le regarde pas c'est comme une vache
se regarde un train passer et pourtant
le chien n'était pas varaschin et le
passe ou pas entre ça ne fait rien le
pass l'autre regarde
deuxième strophe
regardez pensé passer seul avis regardez
pensait passer et l'habiller passer
une troisième strophe
la morale de cette histoire
est carrément arrière
c'est qu'en passant on ne pense pas
passez donc sans penser à l'histoire est
possible
post scriptum
ouf
je félicite mon vieux du snob tu as été
formidable oh non non je peux supporter
pourtant tu m'avais promis
monsieur du snuff votre poème était très
bon mais ce n'est pas ça qui ne va pas
pleurer devant nos âges vous en paierez
15 et mérite ce prix que nous
mais pourquoi pourquoi il accepte ou non
je n'aurai pas mes yeux du cinéaste est
pendante a achevé la coupe mais moi non
plus je suis malheureux mais chez les
stones expliquez-vous maintenant c'est
trop par eux quasi mien m'a tutoyé vous
comprenez il m'a tutoyé
[Rires]
casimir à qu'est-ce que ça ne tutoie pas
monsieur x mobile déteste ça oh mais ça
ne fait rien c'est bien fait nous avons
fait un marché marché mais oui il
n'arrivait pas à écrire le poème tout
seul alors je les écris à sa place mais
en échange il doit me vouvoyer toute la
journée et moi je le tutoie mais
pourquoi tiens tu absolument à tutoyer
monsieur du snob parce que c'est
beaucoup mieux pour te traiter de pau
est minable
casino